رشقات صواريخ واعمده دخان وصافرات انذار
هكذا بدل مشهد في غزه بعدما اعلنت اسرائيل
اطلاقا ما وصفته بوقت الاغتيالات فلليوم
الثاني على التوالي قصف الطائرات
اسرائيليه اهدافا في قطاع غزه منها بيت
لاهيا شمالي القطاع وموقعا تابعا لكتائب
القسام في عسقلان واودى القصف الاخير
بحياه رجل واحد واصاب اخر بجروح خطيره
جاءت الغارات الاخيره بعد يوم من سلسله
هجمات داميه اغتالت ثلاثه من قياده الجهاد
الاسلامي الجيش الاسرائيلي عاد مره اخرى
ليؤكد ان الهدف من القصف هو استهداف
البنيه التحتيه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي كما
اوضح ان الغاره الجويه استهدفت مسلحين
متجهين الى موقع اطلاق صواريخ في قطاع غزه
الجنوبي
مقبيل
[موسيقى]
حركته الجهاد الاسلاميه لم تتاخر في الرد
حيث اطلقت وابلا من الصواريخ ونقلا عن
الجيش الاسرائيلي فان حركه الجهاد هي
المسؤوله عن اطلاق هذه الصواريخ التي
اشارت الى ان حركه حماس لم تدخل المعركه
حتى الان وفق الجيش الاسرائيلي وفي اخر
احصائيه فانه تم اطلاق 469 صاروخا من قطاع
غزه وجرع اعتراض 153 صاروخا افادت مراسله
العربيه بان عدد الصواريخ التي تم اطلاقها
من قطاع غزه وصل عدد منها الى تل ابيب حيث
تم تفعيل صافرات الانذار وتم اعتراض هذه
الصواريخ بواسطه القبه الحديديه واظهرت
مقاطع مصوره هروب السكان الى الملاجئ كما
ادى الهجوم الى تعطل حركه الملاحه الجويه
في مطار بن غوريون
اظهرت صور واطلاق صواريخ على مناطق وسط
اسرائيل وايضا ذوي وسفارات الانذار في
عسقلان في الجنوب نتابع المشاهد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قال رئيس وزراء اسرائيل بنيامين التانيه
هو ان اسرائيل اصابت اهدافا بدقه في غزه
مشيرا الى ان المعادله الامنيه الجديده هي
ان اسرائيل ستحدد الوقت المناسب لاستهداف
قاده الفصائل الفلسطينيه
ضربات قويه وندمر كل من يمس بنا او يعمل
ضدنا هذا هو المبدا الذي نتعامل به في
اطار عمليه الدرع والسهم اوجدنا معادله
جديده نقول للمخربين ومرسليهم نراكم في كل
مكان ولا تستطيعون الاختباء ونحن نختار
المكان والزمان الذي نضربكم خلاله نحن
ولستم انتم بهدوء وليس كرد فعل الخيار لنا
انزلنا على الجهاد في غزه اقوى ضربه في
تاريخها
الاسرائيلي في تصريح له ان المعركه في غزه
لم تنتهي بعد معلنا لان ضربات الاسرائيليه
دمرت انفاقا للفصائل الفلسطينيه ومصانع
للصواريخ
[موسيقى]
دمرنا انفاقا يستخدمها مطلق الصواريخ في
غزه ووجهنا ضربات لمصانع الصواريخ وكانت
ناجحه ودقيقه المعركه لم تنتهي لم تتوقف
نامل ان نصل الى نهايتها قريبا ولكن نبقى
على استعداد وسنستمر كلما لزم الامر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات